- Please welcome Mike
Jackson and Egypt Sherrod.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
- Drew.
- Wow.
You guys are stunning in person.
- Thank you.
- But look who's talking.
- I know.
- We've decided I'm Diane
Keaton in the latest hallmark
Christmas movie.
- You're adorable.
- Is it true, Egypt, that you
guys met during a house flip?
- Kind of, we met before,
you wanna tell her the story?
- We had three different
incidents where we met, you know,
it was ordained.
- Short version, short version.
- We met, the light was
only shining on her.
I said, "That's my wife" Literally.
- Drew, so when he met
me, he actually said that
and I thought it was a line.
So I was like, "Excuse me."
I thought it was a line.
I thought he was adorable.
I mean, obviously, but I don't like lines,
just talk to me.
But I missed out.
So a year later I was working
on a flip house in New Jersey.
I decided to try and tar a roof by myself
and I fell through.
Decided I needed some help, obviously.
And his team showed up.
(audience chuckles)
With his S on his chest.
- Yes.
- And I said, "Wait a minute, I know you."
And he was like, "Uh-huh."
- [Mike] It was ordained.
- "What are you doing here?"
He was like, "This is my
team, this is what I do."
And then he looked really
sexy in his tool belt.
I just couldn't resist.
- Tool belt. (laughs)
- I was standing there
eating french fries,
watching him work, like.
- And then you guys fell in love,
and now you're making a show together.
- [Egypt] That's amazing, right?
It's a blessing.
- You're doing something you
love with the person you love.
- [Drew] Something you love
with the person you love.
Well I love design.
- [Mike] Yes, we know.
- Design's my boyfriend.
(Mike and Egypt laughing)
And I would love to ask you
guys some hot tips, advice,
sort of, you know, gut instincts, takes,
because this is my sexy conversation.
- Hey, let's do it.
- Okay, what is a trend
you love though, right now?
- I think feature walls
are becoming very trendy.
- Well, no, 'cause feature-
- But they're not going anywhere.
- [Egypt] Well, but it's like,
we started with feature walls
for those who followed
HGTV, what, a decade ago,
it was just paint a wall,
and it was a feature wall,
and now we have gotten so
explicit with it, and so creative.
Mike and I would literally
pick up, remember the remnants?
- Yes.
- He had hardwood floor
remnants, and they're sitting
in a pile and it's like,
"How can we use these and make
this amazing art on a wall?"
It's a feature wall.
- Okay, so that to me
is a great design tip.
Now, what is a paint that
everybody should dare to use?
What's a color you dare people to use?
- That I dare you to use?
- Dare to use.
- You know I love blues.
I love moody blue.
What's the one that we
just used, the Aqua smoke?
Oh, there's this color.
It just, honestly, this
color makes me wanna
just make love to my husband.
- What is that color?
Find that color.
- [Drew] Who makes it?
Where do I buy this color?
- It will send your hormones raging.
It's called Aqua smoke.
- Well, okay, so we have
a woman who wrote us in
for a design dilemma, and
she really wants your help.
Would you be willing to guide her through
two spaces that she has questions about?
- We're here for it.
- Okay, perfect.
- [Mike] Bring it on.
- Roll the tape.
- Hi, Drew Barrymore
show, My name is Simone
and I'm the mother of two
amazing, but sloppy children.
I could really use your
help with our entryway.
My kids throw everything
and anything in that space
and it makes the house
look junky and cluttered
before you even get in the house.
I could really use your
help with that space.
- Simone, I so relate.
Simone is here with us now.
Hi, Simone.
- Hi, Drew, I'm so happy to be here.
- I'm so happy to be with you.
You are so stylish.
I'm picking up everything
you are putting down.
All right, Simone.
What is your number one frustration
when you walk in the door?
You said it on the video, sloppy.
- First of all, coming home
from a full day of work,
nobody wants to come into
their home or their space
and like, boom, the crap is right there.
I need help because when it
comes to decor, organization,
that's not, I'm very, I'm not that person.
- All right, well, Egypt,
your solution is genius
and budget friendly, tell us.
- Okay, so get ready for
this, it's gonna completely
blow your minds.
When you take a look over
here at this amazing mud room,
would you be surprised
to know that this is
just a $100 bookshelf?
- [Simone] What?
- [Mike] Yeah, baby.
- [Egypt] A bookshelf.
We completely made a drop
zone out of a bookshelf
that you can buy at a Big-box store.
Anyone can do this, add some baskets,
peel and stick wallpaper in the back.
Depending on the season or
the color that you're feeling
of the week, you can also
change out the wallpaper,
go right on top of it.
- [Drew] And Mike, explain how to do this.
What do you do?
- This is the backing, which is here.
Now, if you notice, this is
three bookshelves put together.
If you did have this,
you'd take the shelves
and you would screw them together
so they would be anchored safely, right?
Now, if for some reason the backing
of that particular bookshelf that you find
at a Big-box store or
maybe a consignment shop
doesn't come off, you may
want to cut this to size
then peel it and stick it on there.
- [Drew] I love an exacto knife too.
- If it does pop off, pop it off.
do it right here on the table or a table,
stick it on there, pop it right back in.
And then once that's said and done,
grab you some hooks and place them
where you want them to go.
Any style that fits your
style, and you're all done.
(upbeat music)